hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about what I believe is one of the most
potent super foods you can consume it's
actually beef liver okay before you
click off just hear me out because
really the key is the quality that you
get you're not gonna go down to the
local grocery store and get liver I
don't recommend that because you don't
know how the animals been processed so
there's a company I'm gonna recommend
called us wellness meats now I'm not
affiliated I don't get a commission or
anything like that but I just I think
they're a really good company because
they're grass-fed grass-finished okay
and they have some great products one is
a beef liverwurst okay check this out
beef liver beef heart beef kidney sea
salt spices onion powder now honestly I
don't like liver okay I was forced to
eat liver as a child I don't like it I
will consume some of it I consume a
little bit of it you know maybe once a
week but if you're looking for
hands-down the most potent
nutrient-dense product this is it check
this out load loaded with b12
okay b12 is for energy it's for
strengthening your blood iron the active
bioavailable form of iron so the iron
from vegetables compared to the iron
from liver is completely different so
this is some serious blood builder
especially if you're female and you're
anemic or around your cycle this is what
you would want to consume as amazing
amounts of vitamin A the vitamin A in
this product is goes right in like a
rocket ship now there's some concerns or
some people saying that you don't want
to consume organ meats because it's it's
going to give you too much vitamin it's
going to be very toxic to you well
that's not true if you look those
studies up those studies were done with
synthetic vitamin A okay it's toxic but
there is a truth about consuming liver
from a polar bear or from a sea lion for
example the vitamin A and that is so off
the charts that that can be very deadly
toxic okay so you but we're not we're
talking about it now we're not talking
about a polar bear but the reason why a
polar bear needs so much vitamin A is be
able to see in the
blinding snow so vitamin A is essential
for vision then you have vitamin E I
mean all the fat side with vitamins
vitamin E is great for the heart it's
good for a woman going through menopause
because your vitamin E drops so low this
will put it right back in vitamin D
vitamin k2 to extract the excess of
calcium that builds up in the arteries
and that builds up in the joints it
makes your bones solid grateful look
acid selenium which is good for
detoxification it's a trace mineral
that's really good for the body great
essential fatty acids omega-3 epa and
DHA okay in in a good ratio tons of
potassium copper coenzyme q-10 vitamin c
zinc folic acid you tell me a food that
can compare with this in nutrients I
want to know type it down below there is
no food that has the amount of nutrients
that liver has so it will give you
strength endurance energy and you don't
need much get it take a little bit maybe
once or twice a week on a keto plan it's
awesome well you don't like vegetables
here's another solution right here so
the thing you need to know about the
liver is that it's the location of where
the body neutralizes toxins not
necessarily where it stores the toxins
that toxins are mainly stored in the fat
cells now if you have fatty liver that's
a whole different situation but the
point is that when you consume liver
there's not near as many toxins in there
if it's from a quality source as if
you're consuming actual fat so the liver
is where you neutralize the toxins it
doesn't store toxins it actually stores
nutrients that's what it does so give it
a try and see if it actually improves
your health
hey thank you so much for watching keep
spreading the word and share this video